Je rentre de vacances.
heu... je suis allé aux États-Unis d'Amérique pour la première fois.
J'y suis allé sans mes parents.
Si, si, il y a une petite différence entre partir avec ses parents et partir par ses propres moyens,
spécialement quand tu rentres de vacances.
bon... et bien... ce mois-ci on va manger... de l'eau.
D'ailleurs j'ai un petit peu faim.
Ah, ça va mieux.
Et avant même de partir, j'ai pu découvrir peut-être la meilleure invention des américains.
Le ESTA.
Rien à voir avec : Como esta?
Muy bien.
Le ESTA c'est le formulaire avec des questions bizarres,
auquel tu es obligé de répondre pour aller aux États-Unis, tu peux faire ça sur internet maintenant.
Je pensais que ça existait que dans les one man show, les trucs comme ça, mais non.
J'ai pu répondre à leurs questions... bizarres.
Avez-vous autrefois été impliqué dans des activités d'espionnage ou de sabotage,
de terrorisme, de génocide ou entre 1933 et 1945 avez-vous participé de quelque façon que ce soit
à des persécutions perpétrées au nom de l'Allemagne nazie ou de ses alliés?
Que je réfléchisse un peu... qu'est ce que je faisais en 1933 moi déjà?
J'étais où?
Qui, sur cette planète va répondre oui à cette question?
Tu m'expliques?
A part pour déconner peut-être.
Et encore je suis pas sûr que ce soit super, super drôle.
Ah! Les Etats-Unis!
PUT YOUR HANDS ON YOUR HEAD!
Merde, comment on dit c'était une blague, en anglais?
heu...it  is a blague... bloug... bleug... blog!
Heu... ahahahah! joke, ahahah, joke!
Oui parce que c'est mieux d'aller aux Etats-Unis quand tu sais parler anglais.
Bon, moi par exemple je parle l'anglais jeux vidéo : yes, no, new game, try again.
C'est pas trop ça.
Il y a un truc que je savais pas en France par exemple on dit : Voulez-vous un Coca Cola?
Et aux États-Unis on dit : Do you want a Coke?
Si je veux de la coke? Heu... oula! Ça doit être un piège d'américain ça, vas-y répond, non.
Heu... No, I want a Coca Cola.
Hé ouais... tu m'auras pas.
D'ailleurs en parlant de Coca Cola, j'ai une petite question pour vous les américains:
c'est quoi votre problème avec les boissons?
Dans les fast-food, là bas, impossible de commander un verre... on te donne un tonneau.
J'avais demandé un small.
Mais c'est un small!
Ah oui!
C'est quoi un large alors ?
Une piscine municipale.
Une piscine municipale de coke.
Il n'y a qu'aux States que ça existe ça!
Et comme tout bon Français qui se respecte et qui va aux États-Unis,
j'ai participé à notre petit rituel: je suis allé acheter un jean Levis, voilà.
Et c'est normal hein, en France ça coûte, quoi, le moins cher c'est 90 euros,
le moins cher aux États-Unis c'est 39 dollars, 39 dollars ça fait 27 euros.
Attendez, laissez-moi calculer, ça fait à peu près... 3 fois moins cher... pour le même jean.
On se fout de votre gueule.
Littéralement.
Franchement, j'ai adoré les États-Unis, par contre,
le mec qui a inventé le métro new yorkais est quelqu'un de sadique qui aime faire du mal aux gens
et faire des labyrinthes.
A New York, il y a des stations de métro qui vont que dans un sens.
Si tu veux aller dans l'autre sens, t'es obligé de faire un demi-kilomètre,
limite prendre le taxi pour aller dans la bonne station de métro.
Et à New York c'est pas une rame = une ligne de métro,
non c'est trop simple ça! C'est un truc de parisien ça.
A New York t'attends sur le quai mais tu sais pas quel métro va arriver,
le C , le A , le E, tu sais pas, c'est la surprise.
C'est lequel? Oui, non, oui, non !
Et quand t'es dans le bon sens, dans le bon métro.
heu... excusez-moi c'est bien la E?
Oui.
Qui va vers le sud?
Oui, oui.
Ok merci.
Par contre c'est la ligne express qui s'arrête qu'au terminus.
Hein?
Encore un blaireau.
La ligne express!
C'est vrai que... c'est tellement plus marrant de faire des métros qui sautent des stations.
POURQUOI!
Mais à part ça j'ai adoré les États-Unis, vous inquiétez pas, hein.
Bon, j'ai un petit peu de mal avec le décalage horaire encore. Mais... à peine.
mais... à peine.
Ahhh!
19h30
C'est l'heure des chocapics!
Ah, ça fait quand même du bien, 2 semaines complètement déconnecté, aucune nouvelle de l'extérieur.
Zen!
En plus à la sortie de l'aéroport, en rentrant, un mec m'a vendu 2 places pour le concert d'Amy Whinehouse,
moitié prix... c'est une affaire!
En plus ça doit être un gros concert j'ai vu sa tête sur tous les magazines people.
Quoi?
Vous êtes jaloux.
Ils sont jaloux.
Merci d'être aussi nombreux sur ma page Facebook
et retrouvez toutes mes autres vidéos sur cyprien.fr, merci, au revoir, c'est marqué en dessous, salut.